my next guest you know from trolls world
tour
he's got a new quibby show called nice
one and of course his great podcast
getting better please welcome ron
funches ron how are you
i'm good moses how are you what a great
conversation you just had
yeah roy's the best right honestly the
first comedian i ever met
that's a good first some people get
really bad first i think the first one i
met was a guy named
chicago steve barkley and his advice to
me was to do cruise ships
so that way i only had to work three
months a year he was doing
great chicago see barclay was doing
great until just this year
everybody knows chicago steve would you
have fun on a cruise ship i can't
imagine
because you want to leave after the show
i feel like yeah the same way but i
don't want to be here
yeah i don't like attention i like
attention when i choose to have it and
then
i'd like it to be over so i would hate
it people coming over to me
thinking that i want to like drink or
hang out you know or continue to tell
jokes
no right or just find a bathroom that's
not in the small room
and i was like i just wanna [ __ ] i wanna
be like you know let's take a photo
first off i know a lot of people that
have had a lot of uh birthdays
in quarantine but not a lot of people
are getting married you just got married
so
congratulations thank you so much yeah
it was beautiful
was it uh what was it like getting
getting married
with the new covered restrictions sort
of a smaller thing how was that for you
i mean it was different of course we
wanted to have a bigger wedding we
wanted
you know and this being my second
marriage is something i never thought
that i would do i was
pretty much after my first marriage i
thought i was scared straight and that i
would not have it happen again so
the second marriage of the lockdown
you've been moving quick
yeah well you know yeah you've been
dating a lot
against the cdc advice
people
that's like this is kind of nice that
you don't have to worry about the two
sides of the family the stress of what
everyone's eating
you could just be with your closest
friends and your son absolutely
you know and i wanted to be able to just
kind of like
scream it from the mountaintop and have
everyone be there but it actually
was really nice to be like oh this is
just for us just for we love each other
it's very low-key and chill and
it was a great excuse not to invite any
racist family members so
yeah that is great to not have to deal
with the
family dynamics i wonder how long
i'm with someone that i for sure want to
marry i wonder how long i could push the
covet excuse
to not do a full wedding to be like you
know i just still don't feel safe it's
20 27 no i think just get it done now
it's j is cheaper
and people get excited about it you get
to wear a fun mask so it looks like
you're getting married in mortal kombat
you get a lot of there's a lot of
positives you're about to fight your
wife
mm-hmm yeah you had a great suit that
definitely to death do us part
yeah and then you fight fatality
a venue's got to be cheap right now you
could have any venue you want it was
just a
fun event and it was kind of like the
opposite of my first
wedding which was like a lot of pop and
circumstance to kind of showcase that
we were pretend we were solid when we
were not
and this one was just like hey we just
love each other let's go get married
we'll come home take some pictures
order some food watch 90 day fiance do
you think part of
having a huge wedding helps in the
i don't know tempting this to get
divorced because i always think about
this you have such a big party and you
speak in such sure
terms at the wedding from the moment i
knew and then everyone gets up that ever
met you
that if you have a bad day in the
marriage like well i'm not gonna get
divorced i told all that
those people how great everything was
yeah now it was a secret so i could just
be like you know what nobody knows no
harm no foul
[Laughter]
never happens like a lot of these
quarantined content shows like no one's
gonna remember this time this is the
time you want to take some wild swings
yeah i think it was the best decision
i've made in a long long time
that's great and and you're locked down
with someone that you love
a lot of people don't have that yeah no
it's it's it's very nice
um that's why i tell her it's like you
know i asked her we got engaged in
november before it and i was like i
think i was 85 percent sure then
but since the quarantine i'm 100 sure
because you are someone that i can be
locked in a room with for
24 hours a day and we we don't hate each
other we just
continue to have fun and laugh that's
really beautiful i feel
exactly the same way um it's a very
challenging time for us
but it is it brought me closer to her
and it made me more sure
like you need that sometimes especially
if you come from kind of i know
we don't have super similar backgrounds
but we come from
but similar in ways and i think
sometimes you're like well of course you
like me now things are going great
like yeah yeah
this is yeah this is we're at my peak
mental health right now but this is not
always
that's what i want to talk to you about
because we did have a similar background
didn't grow up with what would be any
money well below the poverty line
other things happened don't want to put
him on a blast but very rough things
and all this everyone's like this is the
worst year it's still not as bad mm-hmm
as our childhood it still feels like
yeah yeah it's worse than that makes you
feel strong but then also makes you feel
sad well i wasn't feeling great about it
isn't the worst i've been through
you're right it's really not something
to brag about i'm just feeling good
until you said that i was like oh i
thought about it you're sad
yeah you're like oh i've been through
worse you're like i've been through
worse no one should have been through
worse
than this this should be everyone's
worst year
yeah and yeah it's not it is weird
because
part of it feels like i'm prepared for
this and it almost feels like all that
stuff happened for a reason
in a quasi way of like oh yeah that
prepared me for this i could live
without any money i could
you know eat from the garbage and scamp
people and all this i'm not scamming
people now but
no but i understand that i mean that's
kind of just been my mindset and working
in entertainment and where
you know the more i've been acting and
been on set and see a lot of people take
things
very seriously and and as if it was the
end of the world and
and my background my childhood has at
least let me go like well you know
oh what's the worst thing you can do is
fire me and tell me no
and like take the part away okay right
i've been through much worse than that
so um that that has been helpful and
i think you know people have been
through trauma um
either you know they get retriggered by
these these type of things but a lot of
times you like you said you know what to
do
um i knew at least you know for for
my friends that needed it even if i
didn't i go like hey i know
you these are the services you need to
start going and applying for
because there's going to be a backlog of
people rushing to go get them you know i
was selling all my friends that type of
stuff to like you know
apply for loans apply for grants apply
for food stamps apply for everything
don't have any type of
pride that stops you from getting help
even before
you know don't wait until you really
really need it to go get it you know
exactly it's like we're paying into the
system anyways
it's our tax money even though the
government makes you feel like
it's this huge favor it's this huge
handout even getting those 1200
checks out was like we send you checks
every april
every april it's not a problem it's very
discreet how come it's this huge deal
with the government like i i just don't
know how we would get that to you
yeah yeah no that's one of the biggest
trick to to
make like you know asking for what is
owed and what belongs to you
is is some type of charity you know yeah
food stamps have gotten a little better
they got a little more discreet i don't
know when you were on food stamps
whereas i was on it was still the paper
individual things you had to rip out in
front of everyone in the store
no i've been through both sides i
remember the paper and then i remember
having the little credit card that made
you feel like at least
as long as no you know you had some
cashiers who would put it up
and and make sure that it was showcased
to the world but
a lot of times people would just be
discreet you know and wouldn't even go
they go debit credit you pass the car
they and then you know the mean ones go
oh ebt
you know but the cool one right they
don't they're not yeah well there is a
way to tell because they do look like
debit cards it's a very easy way to tell
uh because the ebt cards the food stamp
cards
never work they make sure that you put
it in
immediately goes off it's black licorice
on the back this little magnetic strip
ours never worked they had to turn a key
did you ever see a key in a register
before
yeah yeah yeah it's a missile strike
the two managers had to turn a key
you could eat we had to bomb another
family in a third world country
if you really want this milk yeah and
you did
and you did yeah i just don't understand
why we so much money is going their way
and it's such it's pulling teeth and it
has to be the most embarrassing thing
when it comes the other way
it's like well this is what we pay you
for we pay you for these services
so that you can take care of us in the
rare case there's an emergency
yeah well i think that's you know one of
the
unfortunately um necessary things that's
been going on as people
understanding that um you know these
fail safes that they think there are a
place for them aren't
necessarily true and you have to protect
yourself and protect your family and i
think that's a lesson
that gets taught very quickly to people
of color that
is a lesson that all people need to know
yeah
people need new stuff right now we're
getting to the point i get
march is like there's enough shows out
but now we're at a point where it's like
the all of the movie industry is shut
down things are slowly coming back
but we need new stuff and no one's going
to go back and watch
a season of lily hammer so it's like
well yeah do an autofocus zoom show
it's at least something new at least
trying yeah and sudden trying continue
to get better i've been doing a lot of
things on twitch just
like roy was saying just like i'm trying
to continue to build
an audience and build a community and if
it's if i can't go
out and do shows like the thing that i
love doing is staying at home and
playing video games and
if i can invite people who are like oh
yeah i want to
play a couple rounds with you and we sit
around and chat and they
ask me about my projects and then the
next thing i know they're buying a
shirt or they're or they're downloading
quibby to watch my show and i realized
like oh there's a
value to this in many forms you know
people are hanging out here because they
like me or why would they even be here
right and b i get to build this
community and just actually talk to
people and hang out and play games
and have do the things i like instead of
you know
even on my twitter and instagram and you
say you know the wrong thing i get a
you know text from my manager being like
what's going like what did you do
nobody's watching my twitch currently so
i guess i shouldn't promote it
watching that you've been playing call
of duty yeah yeah i know it gives me a
place to talk mad trash
and
you know talking trash to children do
you go in on the kids or you like you
have a kid and say i'll stay out of it
it depends on how they
are if they come at me toxic if they're
very homophobic or if they're very
you know racist then i just get on them
the whole game but in my way you know
where i just try to reason with them and
ask them
you know why what's going on in your
life what made you act this way you know
and they don't
they're not really usually ready to
handle that
no just an adult speaking of compassion
no
never asked me about my feelings before
are you weeping on the other line
what is so what's the show you're doing
saturday are you gonna have some
audience or is it all like this where
it's all
all digital am i still frozen for you
are you okay i don't know
now i'm back okay yeah all the people
you've had the best setup so far
you've had oh i've been working i got a
ring light i got a
good microphone so thank you for saying
that i appreciate that yeah it shows
it's like a video game toy but it's
you're lit like a beauty blogger
they can see you saturday that's that's
coming up couple days
my tickets for that show uh it sounds
like you're doing it right you got 10
people it's all safe
and then the podcast getting better
highly recommend that yeah it's my
favorite thing to do right now
you know just providing affirmations and
positivity which
can be sorely needed and and sometimes
you know i get in
i get into some however i'm feeling you
know i think this last week i was
very down about you know losing chadwick
and all the things that have been going
on in in wisconsin and
and so sometimes you know i it's
positive but i might speak yelling
and stuff as well yeah but that's that's
very refreshing that's what we need
thank you so much ron funches everyone
thank you
thank you